♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY"
AND TONIGHT WE BEGIN WITH THIS
FOX NEWS ALERT, GUESS WHAT,
EVERY AMERICAN IS SUFFERING,
THERE IS NO QUESTION,
JOE BIDEN'S POLICIES HAVE BEEN
AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER, BOTH AT
HOME AND ABROAD.
AS A RESULT, JOE BIDEN IS NOW
THE MOST UNPOPULAR PRESIDENT IN
THE MODERN ERA.
NOW YOU WOULD BE HARD-PRESSED TO
FIND ANYONE WHO APPROVES OF HIS
PERFORMANCE IN OFFICE.
YESTERDAY, LOOK AT THIS CROWD, A
HANDFUL, 30 PEOPLE SHOWED UP TO
THE PRESIDENTS BIG PUBLICIZED
SPEECH IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP
HELD AN EVENT AND ONLY 30 PEOPLE
SHOWED UP?
WHAT WITH THE MEDIA REACTION BE
THEN?
AND OF COURSE, MANY OF BIDEN'S
PROBLEMS, THEY ARE VERY OBVIOUS
BUT THEY ARE HURTING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HIS OBVIOUS DECLINE IN COGNITIVE
ABILITIES, HIS PUBLIC BOUTS OF
ANGER, CONFUSION, SHAKING HANDS
WITH THE AIR.
JOE'S CONSTANT STREAM OF LYING
AND FLAME AND THE ONGOING
SCANDAL OF FOUR SURROUNDING ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER, AND OF
COURSE THE BIDEN FAMILY
SYNDICATE.
BUT AT THE VERY CORE OF BIDEN'S
FAILED PRESIDENCY ARE HIS
TERRIBLE POLICIES AND ALL OF
THESE POLICIES ARE HURTING YOU,
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BIDEN LIKE ANY MODERN DEMOCRAT
IS REQUIRED TO PROVE HIS LOYALTY
TO THE RELIGIOUS CULT OF CLIMATE
ALARMISM.
HE CANNOT DEVIATE.
IN ORDER TO DEMONSTRATE HIS
DEVOTION, BIDEN TOOK A WRECKING
BALL TO THE GAS INDUSTRY ON DAY
ONE AND PREDICTABLY, GAS PRICES
WENT WAY UP, HEATING AND COOLING
PRICES WENT WAY UP, THE PRICE OF
GOODS AND SERVICES, WHICH
REQUIRE TRANSPORTATION AND
ENERGY, THEY ALSO WENT UP.
EVERYTHING YOU BUY AND EVERY
STORE YOU GO TO IS COSTING A
HELL OF A LOT MORE, AND THESE
RISING COSTS, BIDEN PUMPED
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO WHAT
IS AN ALREADY HOT ECONOMY, MUCH
OF IT IN THE NAME OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ALARMISM.
AND ACCORDING TO ONE
FOXNews.com REPORT, SOME OF
THOSE FUNDS EARMARKED FOR
COVID-19 RELIEF, OH, THEIR
INVESTIGATION SHOWS THEY WERE
USED BY JOE BIDEN'S EPA TO PAY
FOR GRANTS PROMOTING "GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE."
AND ONE NONPROFIT ACTUALLY
RECEIVED MONEY FOR STORYTELLING
AND TREE WALKS TO INCREASE
AWARENESS SURROUNDING AN
EQUITABLE CANOPY COVER.
WHAT THE HELL IS THIS?
NOW THIS ISN'T THE SAME
ADMINISTRATION THAT RAN OUT OF
COVID TEST, MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES OVER CHRISTMAS AND
THAT IS HOW THEY ARE SPENDING
COVID RELIEF MONEY?
NOW AMERICANS FROM EVERY RACE,
EVERY BACKGROUND, THEY ARE
STRUGGLING UNDER JOE BIDEN'S
CRIPPLING, RECORD HIGH
INFLATION.
MOST OF THEM DO NOT HAVE TIME TO
EXPLORE RACIST TREE CANOPIES.
THOSE WITH FIXED INCOMES, THE
POOR, THE MIDDLE CLASS, THEY ARE
GETTING HURT THE WORST COME UP
WITH MANY AMERICANS NOW FORCED
TO DIP INTO THE RETIREMENT
SAVINGS TO BATTLE THIS 40 YEAR
HIGH OF INFLATION.
THE EGO SOCIALIST THAT RUN THE
DEMOCRATIC NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALIST PARTY, THEY ARE HAPPY.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
RETIREES.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT SO MANY
AMERICANS LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK.
THEY NEVER HAVE, AND NOR DO THEY
SEEM TO CARE AT ALL ABOUT THE
HIGH PRICE OF GASOLINE.
WE ARE TOLD IF YOU DON'T LIKE
IT, GET USE TO IT UNTIL WE HAVE
CLEAN NEW ENERGY, AND BUY
YOURSELF AN ELECTRIC CAR.
THEY TELL US THAT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
NEW GREEN DEAL SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATS CARE ABOUT ONE THING:
POWER.
POWER OVER THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
POWER OVER THE WHITE HOUSE, AND
POWER OVER WE, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
CLIMATE HYSTERIA, IT'S REALLY
JUST A FRONT, AS WE POINTED OUT
AT THE TIME THEY UNVEILED THIS
INSANITY, NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT AND EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH REDISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH
AND SOCIALISM.
THE EARTH IS NOT ENDING.
WE ARE NOT DOOMED.
NOBODY REALLY BELIEVES THAT
LIVE.
THE RELIGIOUS CLIMATE ALARMIST
CALLED IS REALLY JUST A MEANS TO
AN END, BUT LIKE ALL CULTS, ONCE
YOU ARE IN, HAVE A HARD TIME
WEAVING, IF AT ALL.
ONCE YOU ARE IN, YOU ARE IN, SO
NO MATTER HOW BAD THINGS GET, NO
MATTER HOW LOW BIDEN'S POLL
NUMBERS GO, HE WILL STAY THE
COURSE AND DOUBLE DOWN AND
TRIPLED DOWN ON STUPID.
AND THAT IS WHY TODAY, BIDEN'S
CLIMATE CZAR, JOHN JERRY,
STEPPED OFF HIS PRIVATE JET
AND ANNOUNCED THE NATIONS WAR ON
FOSSIL FUELS WILL CONTINUE, NO
MATTER HOW HIGH GAS PRICES GO.
JUST GOT OFF HIS OWN PRIVATE
JET, A NICE BIG FAT CARBON
FOOTPRINT HE LEFT BEHIND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FOSSIL FUEL IS ALLOWED TO
GROW IN A SIGNIFICANT WAY AS IT
APPEARS POISED TO DO, THAT IS A
DEEP, UNBELIEVABLY COSTLY
CHALLENGE FOR THE WORLD.
>> IT HAS BEEN REPORTED YOU TOLD
THE WHITE HOUSE NATIONAL CLIMATE
ADVISOR GINA McCARTHY THERE IS
A NEW U.S. COMMITMENT ON FOSSIL
FUELS NEEDING TO BE RELEASED,
50% REDUCTIONS BY 2030.
THE U.S. TO BE A CREDIBLE
NEGOTIATOR.
IS THAT A GOAL THAT IS STILL
REALISTIC?
>> WELL, GINA McCARTHY MAY
SUGGEST A LEVEL, SO GINA AND HER
TEAM AND THE REST OF US WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS ALL
AGREED THAT A 50-52% REDUCTION
WAS SOMETHING WE COULD ACHIEVE.
IT'S REALISTIC.
>> Sean: LET ME INTERPRET THIS
FOR YOU: HE DOES NOT CARE ABOUT
THE HIGH PRICE OF EVERYTHING.
40 YEAR RECORD HIGH INFLATION,
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES, RECORD
HIGH PRICES FOR EVERYTHING YOU
BUY IN EVERY STORE.
HE CARES MORE ABOUT HIS CLIMATE
RELIGIOUS CULT.
ANOTHER TOP BIDEN ADVISOR ALSO
REASSURING DEMOCRATS THE BIDEN
REMAINS ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
BANNING DRILLING ON PUBLIC
LANDS.
THIS IS A DUMB IDEA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN REMAINS
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO NOT
MOVING FORWARD WITH ADDITIONAL
DRILLING ON PUBLIC LANDS.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE IS WE
HAVE A COURT THAT ORDERED A NEW
LEASE TO BE DONE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO PUT IT OUT.
BUT THEY ALSO FOUND WAYS TO
REDUCE THE SIZE OF THAT AND ITS
IMPACT, AND WE WILL KEEP DOING
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO APPEAL
THOSE DECISIONS AND TO MAKE OUR
CASE IN A COURT.
>> Sean: ULTIMATELY, THE
ADMINISTRATION'S WAR ON OIL AND
GAS, THIS IS A MASSIVE SCAM, AS
BIDEN RESTRICTS DOMESTIC
PRODUCTION OF FOSSIL FUELS,
THINK ABOUT THIS, WE ARE BUYING
MORE FOSSIL FUELS FROM PLACES
LIKE IRAN AND IRAQ AND SENDING
EMISSARIES TO VENEZUELA AND
BEGGING SAUDI ARABIA, OPEC
NATIONS, UNTIL RECENTLY, RUSSIA,
THE ADMINISTRATION BEGGING OPEC
TO PRODUCE MORE OIL.
OF COURSE, THAT OIL IS EXTRACTED
ABROAD WITHOUT EPA REGULATIONS,
AND THEN IT IS SHIPPED ON A GAS
POWERED BOAT ACROSS THE OCEAN.
THAT IS HOW IT GETS HERE.
IN OTHER WORDS, BIDEN'S
RESTRICTIONS ARE ACTUALLY MAKING
THE ENVIRONMENT WORSE AND ENERGY
EVEN MORE EXPENSIVE, ALL WHILE
PUTTING YOUR AND OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY AT RISK.
BUT NONE OF THAT MATTERS TO
JOE BIDEN AND HIS FELLOW NEW
GREEN DEAL DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS.
THE ONLY WAY TO STOP THEM IS TO
VOTE THEM OUT OF OFFICE.
THAT IS THE ONLY SOLUTION I SEE.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO CHANGE
THEIR MINDS.
THEY ARE LOCKED INTO THIS
INSANITY.
WE ARE NOW STUCK UNTIL AT LEAST
NOVEMBER, AND THEN PROBABLY
UNTIL NOVEMBER OF 2024.
THESE POLICIES WILL REMAIN IN
PLACE.
THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO DESIRE
TO CHANGE ANYTHING AS YOU JUST
HEARD.
NOW TODAY, SPEAKER PELOSI, SHE
DID UNVEILED THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTIES BIG NEW STRATEGY FOR THE
MIDTERMS AND OH, THIS MIGHT BE
SHOCKING TO MANY OF YOU, BUT THE
GOING TO CALL REPUBLICANS RACIST
AND SEXIST AND MISOGYNIST AND
HOMOPHOBIC AND XENOPHOBIC,
ISLAMOPHOBIC, TRANSPHOBIC,
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY WE WANT
DIRTY AIR, WATER, THAT WE WANT
GRANDMA AND GRANDPA TO EAT DOG
FOOD AND CAT FOOD, AND THEN WE
WILL HAVE A REPUBLICAN MEAN
PERSON LIKE DONALD TRUMP LOOK
ALIKE GRANNY OVER THE CLIFF IN A
WHEELCHAIR.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NOW, I DON'T THINK ALL OF
THOSE VERY WEALTHY PEOPLE AS
RACIST, ANTI-SEMITES AND
WHATEVER.
TRUMPIAN, BUT THAT IS HOW THEY
VOTE.
>> Sean: THOUGHT AND FAIL,
EVERY TWO YEARS, FOUR YEARS,
USED AS A TWO YEARS, FOUR YEARS,
IT IS NOW PRETTY MUCH EVERY DAY,
REPUBLICANS RACIST, SEXIST, THE
WHOLE SPEECH, THEY SAY IT EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
THIS YEAR, THE SMEARS WILL BE
WORSE THAN EVER BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOTHING POSITIVE
TO RUN ON.
HOW DO YOU RUN ON A 40 YEAR HIGH
OF INFLATION, BLAMING PUTIN?
THAT IS NOT GOING TO WORK.
RECORD-SETTING GAS PRICES?
BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES YOU
IMPLEMENTED?
INTEREST RATES ON THE RISE.
I MEAN, THEY ARE GOING UP
PRECIPITOUSLY.
A LOOMING RECESSION, WAR IN
EUROPE, AMERICANS TRAPPED IN
AFGHANISTAN -- BY THE WAY, 249
DAYS AND JOE BIDEN TURNED THE
PAGE AND NEVER MENTIONS THEM
AGAIN.
THE MEDIA MOB NEVER MENTIONS THE
AMERICANS WE ABANDONED.
AND OF COURSE, THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WITH GREEN CARDS ELIGIBLE
TO LIVE HERE APPEAR FOR OUR
AFGHAN ALLIES NEVER GET
MENTIONED.
THE CRISIS ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORD